far from the pageantry pump and party's
litter picking in the rain rounded off
the coronation for these volunteers at a
park near Birmingham
Gary Norris brought his three-year-old
son Samuel along to help I'm a teacher
at a local school in Birmingham and
we've been doing a lot of citizenship in
in lessons so
um rather than just telling them that
there's something that they could be
doing you know I wanted to experience it
myself and come out and help the sparse
landscape the result of a wildfire Here
In the Heat of last summer likely
sparked by sunlight on broken glass
the big help out took place in rather
cooler damper conditions this is a
one-off event for the coronation but
many organizations need volunteers the
year round and they're hopeful that by
coming along to this people will want to
offer their services more often in Leeds
volunteers tended horses that are
Stables where disabled children and
adults can go riding while in Banbury a
game of pin the diamond on the crown was
part of a day of activities to encourage
more people to sign up for regular
volunteering
that for spare time please join us
volunteer and do as much as you can for
the community for some of the elderly
people who come here it's a Lifeline
from loneliness they've taken me out and
brought me here and I've seen all these
pink printer made menu things oh wow
okay both during a cost of living crisis
that's left thousands reliant on
voluntary Services even the Prime
Minister and his wife got stuck in now
this is part of the big help out tens of
thousands of events taking place across
the country just like this respecting
and reflecting that his Majesty's long
tradition of service and its Community
Spirit like this that binds our country
together
no Royal event would be complete without
a bit of planting so Volunteers in Green
Park in London were hard at work it
really builds that sense of community in
the UK and really just giving back and
for us the Royal Parks is really feels
really special to be
um part of that and really doing our
part to get people to give to the
environment which is obviously something
that's close to King Charles's heart
and so it's hoped that the coronation an
event so far removed from everyday life
may have helped bring local communities
closer together
Becky Johnson Sky News